the live stream
all good great uh so thanks everyone for
coming out for the morning session today
uh
and yes so great so for today's first
talk we have uh Dean Foster Dean
probably needs no introduction in this
uh Workshop but
um his work has been highly influential
in the field of calibration and uh
prediction over many years and so we're
really excited to have him here and to
hear what he has to say today
all right
okay
um I've been giving birth to this talk
for Going on 30 years so uh I you know
so I think my first time I get to play
the role of a grand old man and at least
two of the three
um but um so
um I'm gonna probably go a little bit
faster normally do because you all do
have some ideas the first time I talked
to an audience that could know what
calibration was ahead of time so um what
I usually do is I just talk to
statistics audiences and for them this
is kind of what I think of calibration
you have a regression if your data is on
the regression line you're happy if your
data is not on the regression line this
is bad and you know then I spend the
rest of talk talking about you know how
to get your data onto the regression
line and you know standard errors and
things like that and um calibration in
that sense is anything which is a post
processor some way to fix up statements
you're making about the world after
you've seen it so um you know and it's
on that definition so it allows you to
extend it to New areas pretty easily
um and um but the other half they
oftentimes wear is Game Theory so in
Game Theory what we care about mostly is
incentives
um so you know if I ask people just a
general knowledge question you know will
your favorite football team win next you
know weekend
people answer with their enthusiastic
belief rather than with actual
probabilities so just asked people
numbers they just guess and probably
don't mean anything but if you give them
some incentives for example if you're
playing the game of bridge and if you on
a bridge there are certain things that
actually say are exactly a 50 chance
there are other things that you can do
which may be sort of more subjective if
you have probabilities which are not
calibrated you will make bad decisions
so with the right incentives
um in Game Theory you will end up with
um good answers so both of those sort of
approaches are ones where I've given
talks you know drastically now I wanted
to get this on the table because this is
still going to be my world view and so
there will be several complexity
embarrassments as I go along where if
you want to raise your hand and say
isn't that exponentially slow algorithm
the answer will probably be yes
um you know hopefully mostly we can be
patched but you know there are some
points where my co-authors don't
generally say entirely care about
um you know company decision okay so
um in particular I'm going to be
focusing on the online problem that
means you're looking at a sequence of
forecasts you're trying to make and your
goal is to be calibrated now it's an
arbitrary sequence hence the game theory
model so in Game Theory you're trying to
say predict what the other person is
going to do and if you can make good
predictions of what they're going to do
you can use those to make decisions
yourself about what they're going to do
and kind of everything works out pretty
easily so you can reduce a complex
multiplayer game into a single player
calibration problem
um and that's why um you know Game
Theory works out so nicely
um and so let's just to drive the point
of what calibration is and isn't so a
sequence of zeros and ones
um you know your computer people you can
probably figure out this pattern really
fast
um you know odd even and calibrated is
0.5
now
um not a particularly good forecast but
the key thing about calibration is
oftentimes good enough for what you want
quicker than Game Theory where you just
need to know approximately the other
person is going to do now
um the point is that there are things
that are stupider than 0.5
Mike say 0.6 that really is a bad
estimate of this frequency
now um we're going to get to a lot of
today is talking about things which are
you know
better maybe you know
um so this sequence of say 0.1.9 0.1.9
when it has said 0.1
it didn't see 10 of the time
so it is not calibrated
when it says 0.9 it sees 100 percent
so again it is not calibrated this
forecast then fails the calibration and
it's about as far off calibrated as the
0.6 is by about you know 0.1 in some
sense
but on the other hand it's hard to think
of a situation where you wouldn't really
prefer this forecast it just is more
accurate it's closer so that's what
we're going to try to get is try to um
bridge the gap between those two things
okay so
um
um you know calibrated forecasts exists
um I have to throw out a um shout out to
my um colleague sister Hart
um for the shortest proof
um you know apply Minimax
um now um he actually solved that real
time
um in the audience when he first gave
when I when he first heard me give the
talk I had a really convoluted
long-winded proof and um he realized you
could apply Minimax theorem and get it
instantly
um now this will be a first chance where
you could be a little bit embarrassed
for me
um you know this is a game
nature versus statistician
um and you can write down a bunch of
strategies for nature a bunch of
strategies for statistician and it's
just a matrix which you have to solve
the value for and it just happens to be
a two to the 2 to the T size Matrix
cross to the T it's actually bigger than
that it's one over Epsilon in there but
that gets harder to write down so um
this is you know not shall we say the
cleanest way to come up with an
algorithm but it's effective you know
it's as you know just solve this huge
Matrix problem and that tells you what
you're supposed to do okay so
um you know he likes this because it
does answer it instantly as existence
okay so all that you know Game Theory
um statistics isn't what I'm going to
talk about I'm going to talk about
um you know two or three ideas that I've
been thinking about more recently and um
one of them I'm going to call Macau
one's called calabidi and then lastly
we're talking about you know maybe some
fairness ideas so
um those are hopefully closer to
um multi-calibration
um and so in fact I'm going to do three
short talks the third one I think is
about maybe three minutes long
um okay so
um the first one is Macau now if your
geography is as bad as mine you'll
probably have heard of this until I
actually I don't know how I came across
it um Macau is a city in China which
Trump's Las Vegas for the amount of
gambling that happens by an astronomical
amount oh maybe five to one or something
like that so if you think gambling you
should think Macau and I figured that's
a good thing name you know hey I'm going
to be doing a betting sort of um
approach things
um and you know it's kind of going to be
a sequence version of multi-calibration
now that you decide whether it's
identically equal to or just
approximately or similar
um then I'll um do a paper with your
heart on calabidine
um you can always tell Sergio because he
likes cute things and if you've seen one
of those talks there you know just full
of cute things throughout
um so that's his title um and that's a
slightly different version of the same
thing
um and then lastly I'll say a few words
on you know some fairness ideas and what
it is I think we should be calibrating
so what are the things that we should
actually be talking about when we think
about we'd like to have something to be
in calibrated
um so what should that look like
okay
um so
let's start off with Macau so I'm going
to give a quick summary of what it is
because this is something you haven't
heard of because I haven't even actually
published it yet uh most of the math has
been published and written in various
other papers but the sort of naming and
sort of combining together
um is new okay so the idea is we want to
do forecasting for decision making I
mean that kind of is my day job now I
work at Amazon
um you know I was hired to start a
forecasting team in New York and you
know we forecast how many sales we will
make of 20 million products
now we don't really care about the
forecast what we care about is how many
we're going to sell and making sure we
have inventory managed ahead of time to
have it in stock so when you order it
we've got it
um so it's really the forecast is a tool
to get to a decision
and that's um you know why I I sort of
um part of this for past few years and
been thinking about how to make sure
your forecasts are useful for decision
making now you know it says online and
we're invariably forecasting the future
we haven't seen so
um you know as I say in particular the
future is kind of perniciously evil
against us a little bit at least
um you know this is you know every year
um people order their gifts for
Christmas and they say well last year I
ordered it five days beforehand and most
of it arrived on time I can put it off
to four days beforehand and the entire
distribution shifts to be a different
distribution slightly definitely more
evil as far as we're concerned
um so paranoia um is okay but the key
point is can we make forecasts which
would be good for decision making how do
we make that Gap okay and um the point
is that accuracy doesn't always work
um you know the naive story is like well
yeah more accuracy should leave to
better decision making and that's kind
of generally true and certainly it's
true if you're talking about being
closer to probability distribution but
if you're being talking about individual
sequence there is no real probability to
be close to there is no real gold
standard right answer so it's kind of
nebulous as to you know how you think
about
um accuracy except for the point of I
made a prediction did it correspond to
the Y variable that is actually the
outcome that I see
okay so
um you know the accuracy definition that
we will be using is some version of low
regret some version of saying that you
know other forecasts that we could have
done
shouldn't have done much better than we
did
um so we want our forecast to be sort of
the best of breed
okay now um this is sort of 2020
hindsight there's a whole mass of papers
um doing this it's been you know
um hot topic for well you know about 30
years
um and um okay so what I'm going to
argue is that Macau or falsifiability is
the right way to think about converting
a forecast into a useful forecast
so not just one that is close but a
forecast which you can trust for making
decisions so that's our overall goal and
then the um key idea is I'm going to
introduce a something I call the crazy
calibration variable
um and if that plus low regret if you
have those two ideas then you'll have
low Macau which means it's something you
can bet on and if you can bet on things
well that kind of leads to good
decisions because if you're making bad
decisions you'll be losing a bet against
that decision so you set up your bets to
describe how you could go wrong in your
decision making than not losing bets
corresponds to making good decisions
okay so let me walk through these ideas
okay so
um you know the idea of falsifiability
then is I'm going to take as a bet I'm
going to operationalize it as a way of
saying
um Can someone place a bet against your
forecast so I want to sort of claim that
you know y has a forecast it kind of
should be the expectation or conditional
expectation or what have you but I have
no problem so I really can't really say
that
um but what I can do is I can kind of do
something that kind of looks very
familiar from yesterday
um I can have a bet
and I can say a bet will now be a random
variable and it'll tell me when I want
to bet either plus one or minus one or
pay on Personal Taste zero or one
um same sort of thing and
um
my claim is that why Hat's supposed to
be unbiased estimate for y so that means
I'm claiming that this is a fair bet
if I thought that this was always
positive well I should adjust my y hat
to make it bigger I think and always
negative make it um the other way so
um
then operationalize this we have our y
hat that we're really focusing on we
have again this game theoretic approach
B which is going to be created by an
adversary
um and so that means we want to look at
the worst possible B so we'll look at a
bunch of B's and some set
um and that worst B would be what some
you know other player in a game
um is um chooses
um to Annoy Us and then what's a good y
hat well the thing which minimizes this
sort of Macau it's kind of sort of like
a regret and it's very close to a
multi-calibration
um but
um this expectation is really being
mathematically dubiously being used here
because I don't really have
probabilities okay and so then
um what I want to do is I want to find
the best thing I could possibly do based
on minimizing the worst fossil bet yes
function of the the input data
um B can kind of be a function whatever
you want and um so what I'll be doing is
I will be putting say B in a linear
space
and then B will be say any linear
combination of things in that space
so um B might be historical thing that
you're going to understand or in the
multi-calibration B might be subgroups
um so B could be
um properties of the next forecast I'm
going to make as long as I can know what
B is before I make the forecast that I'm
home free
um so okay
okay and your your expectation is
dubious just because you're thinking
about this
yeah yeah
so yes so then so what's the expectation
of the button that you are including um
I'll give a definition now with actual
sequences so um
if you replace this by a sum and a limit
then that would probably work out fine
so um you know if you if if expectations
are hard and this long-term frequency
should I think of Mario in a few minutes
why is it very clear it just seems like
uh
um it's If This Were an expectation
um then why minus his expectation is on
average okay that's okay and we will be
sort of doing Martin Gilly kind of
things
um a little bit yeah just to make sure
you understand the order of play so you
make a prediction and then after having
seen the someone's prediction the other
player makes the bet
does that if the other person knows how
to place bets that you don't know you'll
lose
so if the other person has more
information and if they say they're only
going to bet on things which are likely
to rain and you don't know this property
that they know about the world well then
they'll they'll be placing winning bets
so we do want to have B be something
that
um actually I'm not going to be told
um you know what the outcome is going to
be and why but I need to know whether
they're going to be betting on this
particular point now it's because it's a
Max I really don't know which bet they
are playing places
um so let me actually get to the
actually more mathematical precise
definition and then see if these answers
you know questions go away yes okay so
um let me start out with um my first
individual sequence result
um and that was an online least squares
problem
so the idea is you have a bunch of
historic data you have some x's you have
a wire trying to predict we want to do a
linear regression of Y on x so this is
easy to do we just minimize over a bunch
of betas
um you know what's the best linear
forecast of the Y's
now
um you know
from Amazon's perspective all this is
ancient news I don't care about any of
it the only thing I care about is the
next possible row
so I care about t plus one so that's
what I want to think about predicting
and I need these X's so these X's will
then be our bets or or things that go
into our bets so I want these X's
I have my
beta hat from the previous data where I
didn't know the Y I can in a product
those and get a forecast or Y hat
so this is sort of the real problem that
I have to solve in life where I have my
historical data I predict it once ahead
step ahead and then you know we deal
with the future next year round
um and um now you're doing
mathematically we want to think of this
as a sequence so we will build up all
the possible betas going along and every
single beta corresponds to the data that
comes above it and it can be used for
predicting that row
so if I multiply it by the x's in that
row
that will give me a forecast
so this is online regression and
um the um you know the f is for me
obviously but if you don't know how to
spell my name and in fact some people
have cited this Forester under my
spelling of the name
um and um he did it a few years later
basically
it works out nicely there are several
versions of
um doing least squares and what it says
is that the actual error that I will
make
that's how far away my forecast is from
on the outcome compared to the best
linear combination I could have
um is small
okay so no problem this is a statement
about numbers there's nothing here
really about forecasting you know it's
just a statement about how make numbers
relate to each other so the X's kind of
could be anything
um the X's could say for example the
previous y hats
and um what's kind of neat about that um
with Bob Stein
um we showed how you can make a forecast
better by looking at your previous y
hats without ever looking at a why
and that goes goes to what you're
referred to is we want to preserve
Martingale properties we want to have
forecasts which have Martingale like
properties to them and so we could
identify a Martingale by looking at
previous forecasts of things and um you
know improve a forecast now that sort of
makes sense we're looking at previous y
hats
but that's not what I want to do what I
want to do is I want to look at a
current y hat
now I don't know what y hat is until I
make the forecast but hey this is math
so
um if this column of x's was y hat the
theorem still holds it's just a
statement about numbers
um now
I also have the same y hat four written
over here and they better mean the same
symbol so that means I won't know what
this y hat is until I've done this
algebra over here and if you do algebra
in your head you can see actually it's
just simply a linear equation
um so life is not too bad so
computationally we can solve this one
and
um this is what I call the crazy
calibration variable because we are
using a y hat in as a regression
variable itself
and so
um yeah so so why
[Music]
a t in the in the teeth column
okay so I guess throw it in here
so I mean I could throw it anywhere
yes yeah yeah
that's it yeah it's sort of um yeah
so this beta comes from the all the data
above
um and this y hat I don't know until I
have actually seen all the rest of the
X's
the beta that comes from above and then
I can solve for y f
Okay cool so um Sean McAfee and I did
this idea
um and so I guess it's a nice
calibration that's how we're going to do
is weak um calibration
um and
um what
um we can show then is that if you have
this property here the Y minus y hat
um when you're in a product with the x's
on average is about zero
so it has about square root of T
um you know Macau so this is now a Macau
statement so now we can sort of make
everything fully precise
um I have four casts are sequential
um I had the outcome
and I have
um some x's that these are the bets so I
could actually look at you know two
times one of the X's you know minus a
half times the other one it wouldn't
matter so I had a linear combination of
these X's those are my space of possible
bets and no matter what space Apostle
bets it is it's going to be about PSI
square root of t
so I'm this is actually user definition
so so it's satisfying to say so um and
probably if I want to give it truly as a
definition or just go um little o of t
and this is so that it's so the square
root of T is kind of you know more than
I would need for a definition so
anything is small can you go back one
slide just really quick and like yeah so
this holds when
one of the X's were y hat for some
reason I chose the third one yeah
yeah it's still a true theorem about our
forecast accuracy
um will still hold
so it doesn't matter the fact that we
don't really know what our forecast is
so after we have plugging the bugs
this is a fixed point and this is um
this will I mean um it's a happen to be
an easy fix Point
um anyway um because this is the
function of the x's and we don't know
what that function is to we actually
plug the y-hat
okay
so what we've done here then is
um Macau is effectively a
um normal equation
so statistics we
um we try to avoid ever Computing this
minimization
um that's sort of nasty what we're doing
instead is we'll solve What's called the
normal equations normal in the sense
that these are orthogonal to each other
and what we know is that the minimizer
of this is it exactly the point where
this is perfectly orthogonal so this is
a better thing to solve numerically
um and um you know you have your least
squares if and only if you have normal
equations
um in probability Theory
we can talk about a conditional
expectation and that is some function of
the X's that minimizes this now actually
in probability we usually for some
reason do it the other way around and if
you do the highbrow version of
um you know credential expectation you
say for any other function of this that
product should be zero that's a a normal
equation so in probability the normal
equation holds if and only if
you know the least squares holds now
when you do online
now we don't really have as good on
these squares so we have say low regret
and now we don't really have a normal
equation so we'll have low Macau
that turns out that
um so I guess here's again definition so
Macau I'm guessing I'm allowing
different weights on these access
um so on the on the Macau
um you know
so how do these things work out so the
way they work out is because we're
talking about sort of a linear space in
that linear space already has y hat in
it
now we are doing time series at any
given instant in time your y has a
linear combination of the X's but that
linear combination changes
so that means your y hat is not in your
linear space
so you don't actually get
um this automatically and so
in um you know the online world
regret in this new Square sense doesn't
mean you have low Macau and vice versa
low Macau if you're satisfied your
normal equations doesn't mean you have
low regret
and least squares so you need this extra
crazy calibration variable in order to
get these two things to be um if and
only if
now the way you prove that is by you
know looking at an actual example I'm
not going to try to walk through that
because it's just you know um
equals one but here your
but the definition here so here's a
proper definition Macau
um okay but but it's can you guarantee
that it's lower just so we know that uh
so the somewhere I have a theorem that's
the word
back here
so here um this this theorem is phrased
for a particular X so a Delta function
in weights and if you had a different
weighting on these as long as your
weights are constant over time
so in the coordinates so so you'll be
saying like two times this column plus
three times that column and your home
free
okay
Okay so
[Music]
um this one
so uh stupid question but why is this
not maximizing apple is just either
negative one or one
um you you could um it doesn't really
matter too much
um I mean the proofs basically just do
plus minus one ejects
um and it's just this makes it a space
so it sounds bigger so it's a linear
combination of them and and sometimes I
yeah
okay so so shouldn't
um
so we're trying to make F the initial
expectation so say f is initial
expectation that if I pick any G and I
can now pick the worst G which sort of
falsifies that an expectation okay just
because so normally it's yesterday is
for all G of X
um it should be exactly zero so the
issue is just that you're going from a
linear uh predictors to General
predictors
uh
um okay so
um can you convert Macau into something
useful yeah like you know sort of
Journal pushes to use this for making
decisions I don't really have a clean
answer
um but the idea is that
um suppose I want to solve a problem
online combat domination
um I
see a convex function each point in time
um it's changing
um I want to pick some point that will
minimize all these things after the fact
so what I want is I want to say that my
until my ASA announcing that as an
action my action
should be you know close to having
chosen the best action
but I went with the best action is until
the end of the day
so that's what I'd like to have
um and
um so here's our definition again of the
regrets so I can now if you if I could
draw pictures in latex better or draw a
picture with a nice little you know
tangent line here and this would be an
obvious statement about you know
tangents of convex functions
um and now I can add and subtract a
forecast of this gradient
and
how am I going to choose the action I'm
going to choose the action at the point
where I think the forecast of the
gradient is zero
so if I forecast on the gradient
um do I forecast at every Point well I'm
going to choose an action which makes
that forecasted value to zero so this
term will be zero
and
this is a forecast
which I'm multiplying by some weights
now I guess it's sort of I will need my
learning combination for this
um multiplying by a star well a star is
a constant so that would be just a
weight I don't know what the weight is
ahead of time and if I also then had a
hat as a regression variable
then both of these would be in the span
of my space and so this is a Macau and
it can keep that small by Macau and this
is small by choosing a point with a zero
so that's the idea now
um where this works the best is in um
you know what Sasha and Dylan Foster
have done where they do Square CB
they'll do a forecast of a
um loss and then they'll just optimize
that
okay
um so let's see
um so the proof is pretty
straightforward I'm not going to you
know you know pretend that it's obvious
on as this slide suggests it is but you
just draw a quadratic and it kind of
works out
um every time I try to go through the
slide in detail I've always messed it up
so um you have to read the paper um okay
um okay and but the key point is that
you know typically when I play around
these with these things in actual fact
you end up with
regrets that are log T because these are
you know continuous nicely well-behaved
um functions and macau's are like square
root of T and
um you know Sasha and Dylan
um have a tight proof for that for the
IID case
um a recipe then for good decision
making is you know forecast things you
care about
um but then add this calibration
variable
that will mean that
um you can put in regression variables
and trust that normal equations will
hold and the regression variables
describe how you could be making a bad
decision so I think it's the same recipe
you gave yesterday then that will be a
way that you want to
um you know
you know you you'll solve the you you'll
have protection against those bad
decisions that's part of your best
okay okay so
um for summary then is
if you just do regularly squares
with this crazy calibration variable
then your normal equations hold from a
cow will hold
um and
um so this part is tight
um this part is sort of you know a
stylized fact as they call it in
economics meaning yeah it's sort of not
really a theorem you can prove but it's
sort of a heuristic that you can follow
okay so that's sort of my first sort of
um way of thinking about
um you know a multi-calibration and
online approach
um I want to turn to next is
um the same thing spun differently so
the same idea but with just a slightly
different um spin on it so it says um
you know calabidine
so
um
we have lots of systems that we can use
making good forecasts in fact when I
joined Amazon
um we were using a whole bunch of these
to predict demand
um it turned out that our forecasts
weren't calibrated but they were kind of
pretty smart so I could make it
calibrated to improve it but I couldn't
figure out a better regression to make
it um you know work better now it turned
out a neural net could figure out a
better regression and we've been doing
neural Nets ever since even though I
primarily went to Amazon to escape
neural Nets you know so it wasn't very
good on that escape um you know aspects
so these don't guarantee to be
calibrated start with
but they are good forecasts so we
wouldn't want to just replace them by a
grand mean because that'd be really a
disaster that'd be worse
what we'd like to do is keep that flavor
of quality that they have and make them
calibrated
that's our goal that's what we're
calling tele beating so say that um we
can calibute one of these guys if we are
better than they are in accuracy and
kind of you know who are calibrated in
some sense now it's not actually quite
that definition but keep that you know a
little more okay
yeah so recall our initial zero one
sequence and our better forecast
0.1.9.1.9
we need a way to describe the fact that
this better forecast
um is you know a win and the natural
thing is I'm doing least squares so I'm
going to talk about quadratic error so
we could talk about it has a lower mean
squared error then
the 0.5 constant forecast does
but it has this sort of annoyance
property that it's not calibrated or we
could measure how not calibrated it is
and say that's something that shouldn't
exist
you know it's miscalibrated by 0.1
squared
um you know if we're doing squared
calibration
um
we don't want that to be there so let's
have our Target be our least squares you
know overall just in quadratic error
minus this quadratic calibration term
and after you subtract that off that's
called refinement
um so I will Define it again in a second
with math
um but the point is that
um the refinement is how good a forecast
is if it after the fact was calibrated
so to make that precise
um we can you know go back to classical
statistics where we talk about
expectations and biases and stuff like
that and the bias is how far away an
expectation is from what we claim it to
be
and if we look at the mean squared error
the key point is that is our bias
squared plus a variance term so classic
statistics
um you know it just says that if you
look at the L2 Norm it's your mean
squared plus um your variance
um and um okay so here
um when we go to Binary sequences
our mean squared error now probably you
know showing how easy it was to be
published back in the Dark Ages now
somebody came up with said hey how about
we measure binary sequences by mean
squared error his name was Breyer so
since then everybody has called it the
Briar score
um you know you know most trivial
publication you possibly have
um so our variance will be called The
Briar score
um we've already seen the bias that's
the calibration that we're all very
familiar with
um and probably the new thing is
refinement so refinement is
um going to be this um variance term
okay so
um you know just right out in precise
symbols are Briar score then is how far
away our forecast is from the outcome
quadratic error and
um you write these rejection operators
it works really elegantly
um and the calibration is how far away
our forecast is from the empirical
frequency
and the refinement is how far away our
outcome is from our
um calibrated version of our forecast
so the way I think about this is I make
a whole bunch of forecasts forecast
forecast forecast forecast forecast
forecast forecasts at the end of the day
I say well you know I said 0.7 a lot
I really wish I'd said 0.72 so let me go
through and rewrite history
and that would be my row function
now I'm going to have a lower least
squares so I do that for every possible
constant and
um now I have a way to convert my
forecast my row function converts my
forecast to what I would have liked to
have said
and this then is kind of you can't get
rid of that's oftentimes going to be you
know just intrinsic noise in the world
that you know unless someone can tell
you some magic new pattern
you never get rid of it but the
calibration kind of you're argument
calibration of zero is a reasonable
Target that's plausible
so we'd like to have a forecast that
doesn't have errors in the calibration
side
okay so calibration is fixable after the
fact can we fix it as we are going along
obviously the answer yes because we've
been talking about things like this for
a while
um and
um if we just give some names
um you know okay for calibration R for
refinement
will say a new forecast
Cala beats some old forecast
if it's quadratic error its Briar score
is better than the refinement
so what that means it's got to find the
same patterns that y hat finds
and it's
got to have say zero calibration error
however once we could find a cooler
pattern and some calibration error but
you know that would be sort of a stupid
way to solve it but it's possible
um now obviously I need a little o of
you know terms and things like that
um because I don't necessarily want to
beat it exactly but you know a little
bit of slop be nice yeah
and the online thing this is
everything's online yeah so I need I
need to be able to figure out why tilde
is online also
so I I will be told why hat so we don't
know what out of my head is
we don't know um this answer until after
the end of the day
and we in particular most important the
key thing that goes into that is this um
you know calibration this bias on
corrector we don't know that that will
keep changing to go along
foreign
has found the same patterns that y hat
built into the problem
um without you know being you know
miscalibrated that's sort of the idea of
what it's doing it doesn't have to to be
calibrating it just has to make sure
it's quadratic error is better than the
refinement so it's yeah so so just send
it each other if white hat itself is uh
perfectly calibrated then then R is
equal to the brighter
and so we could just return y tilde
we're home free
um so so so in
uh
yeah so I'm gonna be asking a battle of
that person
so a calibrated forecast calab beats
itself
okay
um obviously we can talk about now
Calamine more than one for no it's going
to be very close to multi-calib
um and multi-calibration
um and
um same story for each of them
individually we want to say that our
quadratic error is better than any of
their refinements
okay now here is
um I think this is so far the only
second embarrassing
um you know complexity thing that I'll
be doing
um so how can we achieve a calorie
beating
um forecast well what I do is I take all
my competitors I chop them up in the
little bins this one said approximately
0.7 this one's at approximately 0.2 put
those into one bin
now I've taken my time series chopped
them to bins on each of those bins
compute the average
that algorithm will calibute each and
every one of the forecasts that go into
it
that algorithm is exponential in
um Epsilon so it looked like one over
Epsilon raised to the number of
um experts
um that we're trying to beat this is not
really an effective algorithm to the
complexity Theory but this is truly the
entire algorithm and the proof is about
that long also
um so
um Sergio really likes this and he's
convinced me that I should talk about it
anyway so I would prefer doing it with
regression you have to be a little more
careful and things like that
um yeah so you can get the same answer
using regression at a complexity that
would not be an embarrassment yeah sorry
aren't just like
your second book is you're looking at
like all possible so all possible
intersections all possible intersections
of buckets that are with Epsilon oh yeah
yeah so if it would be if there are
two-dimensional it would just be a bunch
of little squares okay and
why
like if you looked at level sets because
the problem is that then I will be sort
of in two buckets at the same time
I'll be in a bucket is sort of thing row
here and a buck which is a column and I
don't know which tune I want to dance to
the average of the row may be 0.7 and
the average of the column may be points
two
and if I only worry about the row I'd
announce point seven one over the column
I announced 0.2 but I got to announce
both of those at the same next we've
been a uh so do that and then actually
what you described makes sense and
you're basically are saying here are the
bets that I worry about and um you can
then solve it with that way so yeah
but I I'm going to be going into more
complexity disasters soon so that's why
I wanted to not really worry about this
one minor complexity disaster
um okay
um so
you know calibing things is easy
um or actually in fact effective
algorithms for it
um
you know
the problem though is that
if you use this algorithm just described
um it's going to generate something will
calibrate all the forecasts that went
into it but it's not necessarily
calibrated
so
um
something could calibute it
well then something could maybe calibute
the calor beating of that
um this keeps going on and on and we
work for a long time trying to say it
converged really fast and eventually we
gave up because we were accumulating
epsilons faster than we could um you
know get rid of them
um so what we want to do instead
um
is we want to do a fixed Point like we
did before so if suppose I had C which
caliber it's just a and b well if B
happened to be equal to C
then I have something which calibbeats
itself
that means that
um it's Breyer's score is better than or
equal to its refinement
the only way that can happen with the
same forecast on both sides is have a
calibration of zero
so if I have um
you know see in as one of its um the
things it's trying to beat
we cut the infinite regress off and now
what I can do is I can calibute a
collection of forecasts and be
calibrated
which means I'm protected from somebody
else coming along and calibing me now
they could do it by actually being
smarter and having better patterns I
can't stop that but at least they can't
say you know every time you said 0.7 if
you said point eight you know that'd be
better still
okay so um is there any set of forecasts
then well actually this is basically the
proof in the previous one um you know we
can um
beat that set and be calibrated now the
problem is that this one is a fixed
point this is we can't do is just linear
operators like you did before where I
could say ignore the fixed point just
pretend it's algebra this one is an
honest fixed point so
um
Okay so
anything like this with a fixed point
trying to do we have say two inputs
um C we'd like to have that the the
output of this I don't know what the a
is doing there I guess you know um this
pretend there's no a there
um
and
the natural thing to do is just do a
fixed point
that unfortunately gets us into the
complexity space of of ppad and fixed
Point um problems so we're going to
actually do a a
um slight modification and do something
that is sort of like a fixed point but
using linear program
so what we want is we want to say that
we'd like to have x minus G that's our
quadratic error that we'd like to see I
want to say can I find some distribution
which will actually have a smaller
quadratic error no matter what the
outcome is
this is like the Martingale thing that I
mentioned earlier where I don't need to
know what the Y is to be able to say
that I can always beat this thing here
now
um this can be solved by a linear
program we call this an outgoing
distribution
um and you know it boils down to is we
have sort of space of forecasts if
there's a forecast in the middle and the
outgoing distribution something that on
average equals that point but it's on
the edge of the thing then it's
something where it pushes things towards
the the outward Direction
um Okay so
this you can show existence of a outward
um you know distribution
um using Minimax
sorry really high level question I got a
little confused are you calibrating
online or is it like yeah so in each
step you do the bin updates where you're
looking at all the internet yeah
thank you okay
um now
if we do the traditional approach and
just do a Brower fixed point
we'll end up with a deterministic
forecast
so our forecasts
but it's random could be a drastic
random it'll say sometimes point two at
the time and point seven on a outcome of
a coin toss
um so
um it's not just sort of randomizing
some insignificant bits
um it's randomizing on a sort of full
Distribution on the entire space
um okay so we could get rid of that
randomization by doing a proper fixed
point that unfortunately means that we
are into the um sort of p-pad World
um and that will generate a weekly
calibrated
um that shamanite did a while back and
now what you could do if you want to
kind of do both is you get this weekly
calibrated point you randomly round it
to some discrete points and now you can
get something that is traditionally
calibrated and weakly calibrated and um
this is probably more definition
calibration you ever really care to know
about so let me I think just you know
sort of summarize it
um that if we just do this simple
binning trick
um we end up with something that is not
calibrated
if we do the distributional thing using
linear programming as our tool we end up
with something that is calibrated
but it has the problem that
it's seriously randomizing over a wide
space of possibilities and this bug
statisticians you should never be making
a forecast of 0.2 at the time and point
seven half the time when if you average
those
it would have a lower quadratic error so
we know how to beat this take the
average of all its randomizations it'll
have a lower quadratic error
um but then it could be um you know
calabidin
Etc
um so we can remove that by doing the
Brower fix Point
um but that's a computationally
complexity um harder problem and if we
randomly round um then we get something
both classic and regular Okay so
that's calibing which
um if you want to do it seriously you
use least squares
um I was doing the exponential algorithm
instead Okay cool so let me turn in my
last um you know six minutes to
um you know my third topic which is
um about what should we be calibrating
so what is the thing that we want to
make good forecasts of
so um I'm an Amazon so obviously the key
thing that we want to be fair about is
say hiring
um hiring is seriously economically
important we'd like to have that be fair
um you know luckily I'm not an HR so I
don't truly have to worry about this
um but like the theorists talk about it
um but I'm going to pretend that we're
talking about college admissions because
the language is a little bit easier to
talk about so
um what we should calibrate so I'm going
to suppose that we're thinking about our
inputs to our decision making namely the
SATs
and then we have what we'd like to
accomplish you know our output
um the wide variable we really care
about is you know traditionally freshman
first year grades so the GPA so it's
easier to talk about
um SATs and gpas than it is to talk
about hiring algorithms and then success
at the first performance review
um we all understand gpa's um and
language well okay so
the idea is we'd like to use the
prediction or SATs
um the wide variable we care about that
would like to be sort of traditionally
calibrated over there would like to be
fairness whereabout would be our grades
um but
I'm a game service oftentimes
um you know and so one thing we care
about in game theory is incentives you
know and we want to make sure that we
are treating people fairly as far as an
incentive is concerned
meaning that we want to say that
um or you know be using I think blue and
orange for my two groups
um you know following your lead um so I
want to have the two groups blue and
orange have the same you know motivation
to work hard to get into college
um we shouldn't have a set up so that
one of them has to work a lot harder
than the other one in order to get past
the um fence so
um we'd like to um have that that sort
of incentive fairness rather than just
simply outcome fairness of saying that
the um prediction of GPA based on Sat is
is fair okay so
um the
you know easiest definition of fairness
or or lack of fairness would be if the
forecast for GPA when we know that the
SAT is X for either group isn't equal
so this violation of fairness
um is one that um Richard Posner argued
you don't have to worry about violations
of this sort because yeah rationality
um you know no one would ever do this it
just wouldn't happen why look it just
doesn't occur in the world
um this is a you know over the top
um belief in the efficient market
hypothesis and are that Chicago for long
enough to actually see this used as
legitimate arguments and conversation
where it's like yeah we don't need to
look because we know it will never occur
it's a violation of the market and if we
don't have a local violation of the
market well we never have to worry about
finding them
um
well no it should so if your sats are so
if you're thinking about these decision
making so let's go back to Amazon hiring
that if there is a group that if we
hired them would perform better
we want to hire them
so the most extreme form of this was I
was in Vienna and um Academy St Martin's
in the field had a
um woman conductor and that's a pickup
group she'd picked up almost an entirely
female Orchestra and it impressed me
Anna like crazy they were you know they
made her stay for three overtures I mean
um on course
um and that was because she was picking
people that were based purely on Talent
um this was back in the Dark Ages when
Vienna actually would not hire women
um so um yeah but so the argument is
that you know efficient market makes it
go away clearly wrong
so why
it could be that
your true expectation
expectation a true expectation is
different when you condition well
remember the sat is the arbitrary
definition so sat is meant to be a
forecasted GPA
so you have to take that as read the
thing is sat is a forecasting problem
I think the question is maybe like what
if one group had access to you know a
bunch of sat training courses the other
one and so their SAT score is a bad
predictor and
you know then hopefully the hope is that
the SAT knows how to fight for that
that's what I mean I'm going to ARG
something different so these are all
good points so let me get to my end uh
um
maybe it's completely misunderstanding
the SAT but this sat takes the group
membership as an input
um so to some extent in order to achieve
this see this probably the SATs would
want to actually it would be much easier
to achieve the equality if they actually
had the group membership okay so does
that make like their life easier okay so
um you know this Posner argument annoyed
Ricky and me and so we kind of did some
work to try to show that this doesn't
work out and that's what I'm um you know
talking about and in particular the key
point is that if you have equality
so if you have achieved equality so you
are say hiring people equally likely
based on the outcome of the test and
perform equally well based on the
outcome of how you admit them or
whatever you do
um you still have the problem that it
hasn't been Fair as far as skill is
concerned
so if you achieve this goal the thing
that you kind of in your heart of hearts
probably think that goal is achieving
isn't namely if you have two people with
the same skill level
whatever that means but same intrinsic
ability
um but there are different types
you could still have discrimination as
far as that's concerned you could still
say I had prefer being in this group
over here
um so achieving this goal does not
guarantee that goal the only time that
you actually achieve both at once is if
you have a perfect forecast so your
forecast has any noise in it then you
can't get equality in both of these
so
um you know what I'm arguing is we'd
like to you know have
sat be calibrated given skill
now
um you know what we're seeing here is
that you know regular aggression
minimizes
F you know to predict why reverse
regression minimizes G to predict X
and
um even if f and g are fit by linear
functions
f is not the inverse of G
so the thing which minimizes one of
these is not something that minimizes
the other one inverse and that
regression to the mean effect
um is now saying that this is now our
mortgage really is a regulation issue
because you know Amazon wants to make
good forecasts for good hiring decisions
Society wants to have good incentives
and fairness for skill definition so
we're all being treated equal and we
can't achieve both of these so
um sort of Regulation has stood in my
mind push that we are forced to use this
one in spite of the fact that colleges
and you know employers and everybody
else would prefer using that one so um
you know this problem with regression
mean and
um let's see I think so I just you know
kind of end with here that then the you
don't get skill so probably the best way
to do that then is simply do the
regression the wrong way around
what you want is you want your SATs
to be calibrated
given the outcome variable so given
their GPA
so this is a different form of
calibration than the more traditional
one that universities typically worry
about which is they would like to know
that everybody admit is likely to
succeed that's their forecasting problem
um this is arguing for incentives and
you know game theoretically
um trying to keep everybody Fair
um we um we want to go the other way
around
okay so
um a bunch of papers
um I like you know on screen you know
click on these things uh like how
um I actually saw some printing out with
blue underlines that you've on paper
that you really truly can't print on so
um you know if you go to my website um I
think there's under Simon's as a talk
um and probably we can post somehow and
the key point is there's one Foster me
there's another foster Dylan
um and there's a third Foster
um who did also these squares
um okay so
um takeaways crazy calibration is neat
um you know there's multiple ways to
calibute and do your regression the
other way around okay thank you
okay let's take uh
there's gonna be some seriously
[Music]
foreign